two British scientists are finally
revealing the DNA evidence they say help
solve one of history's biggest crime
mysteries the identity of Jack the
Ripper back in 1888 the notorious serial
killer murdered and mutilated the bodies
of five women in London vladimir
duthiers our streaming network that CBS
n shows us why an immigrant from Poland
is now a leading suspect black good
morning to you good morning the savagery
of Jack the Ripper's crimes terrorized
the residents of London no one was even
charged although the police have had
their suspicions now more than a century
later modern technology may have finally
unmasked the elusive killer few
criminals have captivated the world's
imagination like Jack the Ripper Oh to
give a different pretty killer this silk
shawl is believed to be the last piece
of physical evidence left from his
killing spree more than 130 years ago
two biochemists who analyzed it say they
detected the DNA of Catherine Eddowes
Jack the Ripper's fourth victim in
apparent bloodstains
they also found a semen stain they
believe came from Aaron Kosminski a 23
year old Polish barber who at the time
was a prime suspect researcher David
Miller I think the fact that there are
two to signatures which appear to match
signatures from descendants increases
the confidence that were looking at is
something which is real Miller and his
co-author published their data for the
first time in a scientific paper last
week they said the semen stain contained
fragments of mitochondrial DNA genetic
material children inherit only from
their mothers that match chose Minsky's
living relatives author Russell Edwards
who hired the scientists to conduct the
DNA tests originally disclosed the
findings in his book naming Jack the
Ripper he spoke to Sunday morning in
2015 we've proved this you know all the
story absolutely fits like a jigsaw
puzzle I think they come up with rather
convincing evidence dr. Stanley Nelson a
UCLA professor of human genetics says
the DNA case against coast Minsky is
strong but not completely ironclad
they're not identifying a unique person
X is about one and
fifty to one in a hundred individuals
and modern England have this
mitochondrial type Kosminski died in an
asylum in 1919 the British biochemists
say their original aim was not to learn
Jack the Ripper's true identity but to
see how far they could stretch modern
scientific techniques to analyze make
minut DNA samples that were over a
hundred years old beyond once again
modern science solving age-old mysteries
right thanks Vlad